c'est dans la bourgade de notre dame
d'oé au nord de tours que les abalo a
installé son petit atelier alors qu'elle
ouvre d'habitude ses portes à l'occasion
des journées européennes des métiers
d'art le coc vive la prive cette année
du contact avec les visiteurs
elle a donc naturellement décidé de
s'investir sur les réseaux sociaux en
publiant régulièrement des vidéos et des
photos illustrant son travail et c'est
son compagnon mathieu qui tient la
caméra à l'occasion de l'arrêt de
profession je suis vidéaste et comment
ça se passe tous les jours vous y mettez
les deux fois par semaine là c'est
vraiment que trois étapes dont classe et
c'était juste pour ces trois étapes la
diplômée de bijouterie et d'horlogerie
les a créés depuis trois ans ses propres
collections
spécialisée dans l'acier bleui elle
prend le temps de décrire ces techniques
aux internautes un véritable cours en
ligne qui a de plus en plus de succès à
en juger le nombre grandissant de ses
followers aussi bien sur facebook que
sur instagram métiers d'art et réseaux
sociaux deux mondes qui semble ne rien
avoir en commun mais qui finalement
révèle une vraie complémentarité la
puissance informatique et de l'image au
service de la tradition et du savoir
faire
j'ai décidé de me développer un peu plus
en fait parce que c'est important de
montrer son travail sur tout le monde il
veut dire le mien parce que c'est ok je
fais des bijoux mais ils sont différents
des autres
en fait si c'est d'innover avec des
techniques ancestrales métaux reloger
les coûts en fait c'est fait des bijoux
qu'on ne va jamais ailleurs les journées
européennes des métiers d'art se
tiennent jusqu'à la fin du week end
l'édition 2021 n'a pas été annulée
malgré la crise sanitaire
quant à léa elle poursuivra son
expérience sur internet et les réseaux
sociaux
elle souhaite même sans faire une
nouvelle vitrine